Benjamin burn from uh Friedrich Schiller
University of Vienna and talking about
cdcl versus resolution in qbf yeah
thanks very much
um so this is based on joint work with
Olaf Firestorm from Ina in Germany not
to be confused of Vienna and Austria and
Thomas pilot from Vienna and Austria
um
but we already heard a talk today about
ubf where we we have seen what is the
connection between qbf and circuit
complexity and now we're interested in
well qpf solving in terms of qctcl and
yeah qpf proof systems that are based on
resolution
so luckily I don't have to explain too
much about qpf because we already heard
that so let's let's just make a quick
reminder for you so we are dealing with
cool universe
um
a prefix that are quantifiers and Matrix
that is just the propositional formula
in CNF
and we want to find out if our formula
is false
or true and if it is false we want to
return a reputation and if this is true
we want together yeah the opposite of a
reputation I would say is a verification
okay
so we also heard about uh qpf proof
systems before
but we only I think we only defined um q
u resolutions so let me start with Q
resolution because this is naturally the
the first one you would Define
um but first let me say that in our
settings I said here we we want
reputational verification
in our setting we will only concentrate
on false formulas and refutations
because verifications work a little bit
differently than uh are a little bit
more complicated so for our setting here
where we want to find separations and
lower bounds and so on it's it's enough
to only consider false formulas but keep
in mind that our formulas might also be
true in general
okay and for for work here we consider
three refutation proof systems the first
one Q resolution or short cures
which was introduced in the 90s by by
Kleiner Bruning Kapinski and flogo
this is just as you know the extension
of Q of propositional resolution and you
have already seen this resolution rule I
don't have to explain this here however
here in key resolution we have this
slide
um restriction that the the x or pivot
has to be existential
and crg is uh should be non-podological
and we have this reduction rule as
you've already seen
that we can just get rid of the U if
there are no existential literals right
of you
in this class C or U
and
um as you already know this it would say
a reputation it's just a derivation of
the empty Clause so we want to get the
empty Clause somehow
and there are two more systems or even
three but we only consider the first two
systems
um the first one here is long distance Q
resolution or short LD QRS introduced in
2002 by Shang and Malik now I won't
explain this in detail how this is
defined because it would take too much
time
just let you know that it is basically
like hero resolution but it allows some
search and resolution steps that were
forbidden before
but for the stock it's not critically
important to know what these extra rules
are
and yeah you've already seen uu
resolution introduced by Angela 2012.
um
which is just key resolution but we are
also allowed to resolve over Universal
neutrals
and you can also combine these two
systems into this long distance qu plus
resolution or ldq you plasters
we lost 40.
okay now you've seen how our reputations
might look like
uh here's the simulation order of these
uh reputation resolution based gpf
systems so the weakest one is the
Securus
Brave natural to see that it's the
weakest one and then ldq Reds and qures
are
because it's correct to say they are
equally uh strong but they are
incomparable but they're both stronger
than humorous and the strongest one is
that's ldq plus res
now
now you know how your reputations might
look like
no question how can we obtain such a
refutation
and luckily
the first talk today we also heard about
cdcl and
[Music]
we can just lift cdcl to qcdcl which is
the qpf case for the cdcl
um which is one of the main not the only
one but one of the main paradigms for
qbf solving and upgraded this little
picture here
um so qcdcl Works similar to cdcl but
there are some slight differences
so maybe let's see you start up here you
have you have your Cube qbf or QC and
fqbf and CNF
um you check if
at the beginning if it is falsified or
satisfied so usually check if your
Matrix is falsified or satisfied
naturally this should not be the case at
the beginning but it will be important
later later runs so let's say it's not
qualified and not satisfied so we check
if there are unit Clauses or unit terms
so that's that's Now new that you also
check for unit terms because you need
terms for qbfs the term is just the the
opposite of a clause
um and if there are any unit Clauses or
terms you do unit provocation and if not
you make a decision and then you go up
here again and check again and at some
point
um
you will either falsify or satisfy your
Matrix
if you falsify it you just learning
Clause like you know from cdcl
if it is the empty Clause then you're
done because your qpf is no false if
it's not empty then you can learn this
Clause you can add it to to your Matrix
and backtrack here and start over again
some crucial difference in qcdcls that
if your Matrix gets satisfied then it
doesn't mean that the whole formula was
true
because might be the case that there is
a there are false qbfs where you can
satisfy the Matrix but they are false
because of the the qualifiers
so uh when we satisfy the Matrix at some
point we we instead learn a term and
only if this term is empty then it is
true otherwise we we also add this
tournament
do backtracking
but again we only concentrate on Force
formula so this this left side here is a
little bit more important for us
now
um what do we know about the the
connections between
qcdcl and yeah resolution based systems
so far
so as I think many of you know that the
DPL corresponds to three leg resolution
because here you get this uh decision
trees and if you flip them you exactly
it's a three like resolution proofs
then in the in the sub case and cdcl
from cdcl you also have seen that you
can extract resolution reputations
but a surprising result from 2011 showed
that the other direction is also true so
you can basically
extract cdcl runs out of a given
Resolution Group that's pretty crazy I
would say so therefore you could say
that cdcl if you interpreted this as a
as a proof system
is equivalent to a resolution
and now we simply ask the question for
for the qpf case yeah what is the
connection between qcdcl Q resolution or
qcdcl and ldq resolution the only thing
we know so far is that we can extract
LD QRS proofs out of qcdcl because that
was the whole purpose of defining
leqrest to formalize qctcl a little bit
okay so here you can see at which point
in this whole graphic
um this whole algorithm we can extract
these proofs
uh this is exactly here when we learn a
clause
there we can you know you already know
that uh in cdcl you can extract
resolution proofs and here you extract
ldq rest derivations of these fluid
clauses
and at the end you will you have the MD
clause and therefore you uh you get the
derivation of the empty clause and you
can stick together all these derivations
and get one big refutation or pure
complete formula
now what can we say about Q60 versus
resolution coming to this question
now that was the the first result of our
paper from 2021 and we've shown that um
actually qcdcl the classic qcdcl as we
know it and Q resolution are
incomparable as proof systems
that means Texas separations in both
directions
however we can
slightly modify this qcdcl which I will
explain later a little bit more detail
and then this modified version of qcdcl
resolution
now um if you think about it so I said
that you can extract ldq rest proofs out
of
qcdcl and ldq Roots as a strong approved
system than cures but uh qcdcl cannot
even simulate keywords itself which is
the weaker one so why is that the case
what is the weakness of this classical
non-modified qtd cell why it does it not
work we simulate a q resolution
now I won't I have another time to
explain this in detail but um
this was from also from 2021 from our
sub paper we have shown that there
exists a lower bound technique so not
only one lower bound but the whole
technique
of classical qcdcl
at least for a particular class class of
formulas
like I said I won't explain this here
but the thing you should
or I should point out is that this
technique exploits the fact that
decisions need to follow qualification
order I think this is one something I
haven't talked about before so when you
make a decision in classical in the
classical setting
these decisions tests have to follow the
quantification order
what it's done in practice
and well this uh
gives us this weakness for for key
resolution
how can we modify qcdcl to make it
equivalent
or as strong as Q resolution long
distance key resolution and so on
so our purpose is to to find out if
qcdcl can theoretically as a proof
system reach the strength of these proof
system diapers that we find before and
for this we we applied three kinds of
so-called policies which are just these
modifications
to qcdcl
so these are decision policies reduction
policies and propagation policies
um I will go through all these
explain them how they work and where
they work let's start with decision
policies
now this happens here of course this is
the only point where we make decisions
right after uh
uh not finding any unit Clauses we have
to make a decision and like I said in
the classical setting we have to
the pointification order
however this is not good because of our
lower band technique
so idea is just to allow arbitrary
decisions that do not follow
quantification order it's that easy as
it sounds
so now we have these these two policies
the first one levort which is just level
order decisions so
positions that follow the quantification
order and the other one any ORD people
can use any order as uh decisions
and then from our original approve
system qcdcl or algorithm
we get two
the first one qcdcl lab board which is
just all classical but we just call it
uh qctc lab or now to see
which policy is included and the other
one qctcl any Ord
now um
unfortunately this is not enough to to
simulate key resolution proofs what we
also have to do is we have to change the
way we reduce literals
and we here are looking at reductions
during unit propagation so of course
there are other points where where
reduction can be applied for example
here when we learn a clause and of
course when we learn clauses
we all also reduce universally but here
we only care for uh
reduction during unit propagation
so for this I should explain how unit
propagation in qcdcl works
so we all have already seen how it works
in cdcl just classic uh you have a
clause
and a few falsify all the tools except
for one then you have to set this one
remaining literal to true and this is
the unit propagation in qcdcl
it's a little bit different but but
similar so if a clause becomes unit
under the current assignment you made
you know in your Trail in qct cell and
after reduction Universal reduction then
you have to satisfy this cross
for example
let's consider this Clause here X or U
or Y
um and your prefixes let's say x is X
for U with x x y and you just have
assigned y to zero
then if we apply this assignment to to C
then you get this X or U this is not
particularly a unit Clause but
accusative it works as a unit Clause
because you can simply reduce this U
because nothing is right of you
yeah so therefore you have to set X to 1
in the setting here so this is how unit
propagation Works in qcdcl
compared to cdcl
however
it's a little downside with these
reductions during unit provocations
because all these reductions
are kind of uncontrollable if you want
to simulate a q resolution with it
because they all pile up during the
course learning all literals you you
reduce your immune propagations
come back again when you learn a clause
and there they can prevent further
further resolution steps that's not good
uh
therefore we just forbid reductions at
all
and Define these two policies that
affect these reductions during unit
propagations so here the first one is
just a classic one all red that means
always where you use Universal reduction
in unit propagation in the next one no
red just use plane
unit propagation asset cdcl
so now we again double the the number of
our qcdcl variants we have defined and
now we get four of them for each
combination once
again the the leftmost here is the
classic one uh where we started with and
this is uh the most modified one
now we can make this interesting record
here
if we take this this one here with any
or that means arbitrary decisions
and no reductions during unit
propagation we can show that this
particular variant of qcdcl
as a proof system is equivalent to Q
resolution so now we have succeeded to
to reach the strength of Q resolution
via at least some modified version of
qcdcl
well that's that's pretty nice but uh
you've seen at the beginning the Q
resolution is the weakest of these
systems so why not go further maybe we
can extend it through to long distance Q
resolution
um
so how do we gain the strength of long
distance key resolution
for this we have again go back to the
reductions and
uh for for an LD QRS proofs we need at
least some reductions during unit
propagations
but they still need to be controllable
the idea is that we just use uh we just
choose which literals are to be reduced
and which not that means sometimes we
can reduce sometimes not
this is what this new policy this new
reaction policy any red means
that means we get to
additional systems here with with us any
red reaction policy
and with that uh
unfortunately we cannot
it's it's not enough to to modify to to
uh simulate long distance curious proofs
because we have to modify long distance
itself
I cannot explain this here in detail
because it would take too much time but
just trust me that you need to modify
also these long distance proofs a little
bit and for this we we Define this new
model here this new System modified LT
cures or MLT cures and an important
result here is that this is not just
defined on the Fly because we we just
wanted it
um but all previously defined qcdcl
variants that means
all of these
um
and including the classical qcdcl are
still P simulated
by this MLD QRS
okay so basically you know you do not
actually need this LD cures anymore you
can just take this this modified version
which is a slightly restricted version
of the
and then
we can get to the next result
we take this qcdcl with arbitrary
decisions and arbitrary reductions
uh this model is uh able to to be to to
simulate these mldq rest resolution
proofs therefore it's equivalent as a
proof system to this mrd cures
okay
are there any questions so far
I don't know how much time I've left
seven minutes okay
okay so what I what we have seen so far
um
we have uh yeah characterized
uh three like resolution via DPL we have
characterized uh
resolution via cdcl this was already
known
um
we could not characterize Q resolution
but the classic qctl part of the
modified version of that and we could
even do this for this modified long
distance QRS and now the remaining
system we want to look at is Q us
and for this we have to look at the the
last kind of of uh policy of
modification policies for qcdc elevator
propagation policy and we also looked we
will we already looked at propagation
but now we want to
to change the propagation itself
or aim is to find a qcdcl model that
characterizes quras so on qures we are
not only allowed to uh resolve over
existential variables but also over
Universal ones
so what we have to do here we have to
allow
unit propagations also over of universal
literals this was by the way inspired by
uh
I worked by physics devoski last year
and he was also implemented this
so now we get two more policies the
first one which we call XC prop which
means that unit propagations at least
via Clauses are only allowed for
existential variables and all prop which
means that Universal added unit
provocation
can be done for existential and
Universal variables
you can double the amount of performance
but I have to say that okay if we have
12 of them now but not all of them make
sense and not all of them are
interesting so you can ignore some of
them so for example it doesn't make
sense to combine all reduction and all
propagation it's all red and all prob
because you cannot propagate Universal
literals and reduce them at the same
time
okay so from these 12 systems we look at
this one and we finally come to the to
the last main result here
um
which says that this
this variant with any reduction with uh
arbitrary
decisions no reductions
and potentially Universal propagations
is equivalent to gu resolution so we've
also characterized career resolution now
okay
so onto the last slide so this is
another overview of all the I would say
interesting systems we have looked at I
haven't talked about every uh
every connection here
these are all included in our papers
just to point out
this one here is the one that
characterizes this mldqres this one
characterizes cures this is the the
classic qcdcl and
um what I also want to point out is
that from all of these you see many qcd0
variants here and from all of these
variants only one variant is really used
in practice and it's implemented this is
that one
as you see it's uh
lots of stuff
which could be better variant but yeah
and I want to therefore I want to end my
talk with a FP link to all the the uh
the practitioners out there who work in
qpf and say them but
perhaps the most popular
algorithm not always the best one
thanks
thank you uh question
so I have a question Are there specific
I mean you mentioned what people have
done in uh in in
actual uh you know in implementations
are there particular pieces you've got
three different components and slight
variants in each aspect are there
particular components that you think are
going to likely be the most productive
in terms of adding to what people have
implemented well uh what we at least an
experimental setting try to implement or
how much did this was this any order
and we found out that actually on on
these formulas for which we use for the
separation it turned out that you really
see the separation also in experiments
and
um
there was at least one so we have a
different version of that but there was
at least one variant of this any order
uh that also was was better even on
Benchmark formulas than the classic qctl
so yeah I would say that that at least
these
uh arbitrary decision orders might be
really a good idea because we really see
that otherwise we have this lower bound
technique and
the other ones are not so clear so for
example
I mean when we say any reduction so we
you can you can choose when to reduce
and when not it's not clear how you
choose that in practice but yeah some at
some point you you should think about
this because in theory you know that's
better so doesn't the same
to how to choose the next decision yeah
right right that's why we we try
different uh different versions of any
other day so we also tried some
restricted versions of any order right
it's not really any order but some
heuristic is
but it's it's uh it's more liberal so
than any level or that's important
so you said that from this team cdcl
runs you can extract ndqs proofs that's
the original so those runs do not use
term learning right
um no we only concentrate on
yeah
but so when you're when your formula was
false
you might have learned some terms but
you can ignore them because if it turned
out to be false you you never lose these
terms in your application so
they're still there that you you've
learned them during your algorithm but
during your runs but
they don't shorten the reputations
well uh learning curves it's important
it can also help or it can be helpful
for uh pause formulas as well but they
don't turn up in the reputation
so so even if the algorithm is running
on a false formula and is learning terms
along the way you can still extract an
individual presentation
yes
questions okay let's uh thank you again
[Applause]
okay